hey guys my name is Jess McDonald and
this is our top 5 show where I give you
my five favorite stories of the gaming
week so you can boast to all your
friends about how caught up you are on
the gamey happenings first things first
copies of notoriously terrible Atari
game et which were buried in landfill in
1982 have been dug up Microsoft who is
making a documentary on the crash of
Atari and the legend of the Buried games
commissioned the dig the search was
initially approved in June but it took
until early last month for Microsoft to
finally get the go-ahead whilst
ruminating on the terribleness of et has
been a shared opinion you guys have
mostly been discussing what should go
back in the hole the most popular
responses at the moment seemed to be
connect copies of aliens colonial
Marines and copies of nap let me know
what you'd put in the hole if it was up
to you yes that's something I actually
wrote down and decided to say in an
Internet video some of you guys were a
little bit upset that h1z1 sony's
upcoming zombie MMO wasn't included in
top 5 a couple of weeks ago so here it
is for you now a new trailer has been
released which looks like DZ but with
less being shot at and amis by other
players it's mostly plagued with zombies
running at the screen before the woods
will you survive a thrown up and then it
has one of those creepy post title
screen frights which never fail to catch
me off guard according to the dev the
free-to-play game is coming to steam
early access sometime over the next few
weeks according to industry research
company DFC pc games make more money
than their console counterparts it
didn't used to be that way around but
analysts are claiming it's because
consoles are a luxury item while species
are seen to be a necessity giving them a
broader audience as with genres MOBAs
like dota 2 and league of legends are
the most popular in terms of usage
regardless of this switch it is expected
that the newgen
consoles are likely to push revenue back
toward their favor sony has told
investors that they expect a post what
is amounting to a fairly significant
loss this financial year even though the
ps4 has been going strong the very
unimpressive sales with its vaio laptop
have impacted pretty heavily on the
company who are bracing for the
equivalent of a 1.3 billion dollar loss
aside from that Sony's disc
manufacturing business has lost them a
bunch of money since consumers are far
less interested in physical media than
they once were and lastly this week the
cast for Star Wars Episode 7 has been
announced I know it's not strictly
gaming news but think of the future game
teens also I think it's pretty cool and
this is my show so I can probably do
stuff like this han Leia Luke c-3po
Chewbacca and r2d2 are all returning and
will be played by their original actors
as the newbies there are relative
unknowns like john-boy Yeager and Daisy
Ridley as well as household names like
Andy Serkis who played golem and Max von
Sydow of The Exorcist let me know what
you can about this week and if your
verdicts for the Star Wars cast is day
or nay if you prefer you can head over
to my Twitter and share to me directly
where I'm at just looked on this week on
site seven can get a fright or two in
Skyrim mods we answer all your watchdogs
related questions and reality check
covers off on whether we could colonize
other planets that's it from us this
week thanks for sticking with us as
always and be sure to please consider
having a star wars marathon on sunday
i'll see you again on monday
you